the Internet it's a place where you can
see incredible things like glamour shots
of cats angora show bunnies or even this
rare heartbreaking footage of an injured
world war one soldier returning home to
his pregnant wife
new idiots I got you so good
I got you so good the internet has been
blowing our minds with its power and
convenience for decades as you can see
in this actual AOL ads from the 90s hey
Dan ready for the game I'm just
finishing up here with my new kayaking
friends kayaking friends on your
computer yeah I just got America online
sounds great listen I can't go to the
game today what I've got to send
something for my mom's birthday it's
tomorrow I'll then book plane tickets
for our trip next week and my kids got
to go to the library to look up
dinosaurs hey we can take care of all
that before we go Yeah right
Oh with America Online wait let me get
this right
your mom's birthday is tomorrow your
trip is next week and you're only
planning both of those things now forget
the AOL tutorial let's talk about basic
responsibilities here dad you're a
father but what is the act as the ad
goes on to point out the internet was
going to fix everything call now for ten
free hours of America online and get
instant access to the worlds of sports
finance computing and entertainment here
come the dinosaurs I saved you a trip
the library that's great yeah that
Laurie is easy too you know I can even
send email on the internet of course
it's my personal favorite live chat
that's how I met my new kayaking buddies
okay okay okay I'm now pretty sure that
kayaking buddies is a euphemism I'm not
saying that he's not going to meet his
new buddies in a shed by a lake I'm just
saying there's not going to be a kayak
in though amazingly that ad was 20 years
ago and the Internet has become integral
to modern life but unfortunately it's
also become a haven for harassment and
I'm not talking about everyday internet
abuse of which I am more than aware look
at our YouTube page and you'll see
comments like this guys are
dumbass I don't know why but I always
pictured John Oliver as a puffin
and watch his hands his fingers are like
creepy spider lives which is ridiculous
because I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about the kind of direct threats
that can make people fear for their
safety and if you're thinking well come
on that doesn't seem like that big a
problem well congratulations on your
white penis because if you have one of
those you probably have a very different
experience of the Internet women in
particular can receive a veritable
cornucopia of horrifying messages online
just listen to one female video game
we're discussing one of them all
colorful threats that she's seen I think
the one that always sticks out in my
mind is uh I'm going to stick an egg in
your vaginal canal and punch it it's
poignant it is kind of poignant
fun fact for you I'm going to stick an
egg in your vaginal canal and punch it
was actually the original title of Eat
Pray Love so and that threat was
comparatively mild others can be
chillingly specific and potentially
dangerous listen to how these women were
treated when they spoke out against what
they saw as sexism in the video game
industry I'm constantly aware of the
fact that there's an enormous amount of
hate directed towards me hate in the
form of bomb threats rape threats even
death threats they told me they were
coming to kill me when someone posts or
address online and they tell you that
the murder your whole family you don't
really feel safe staying with that
location yeah no I wouldn't blame
her for not feeling safe staying on
earth for the record if someone did that
to me I'd hit you right to the
International Space Station straight
away except Who am I kidding they'd
never let me in
I've got spiders for hands
the internet is mean look this this does
not just affect women in gaming it can
potentially affect any woman who makes
the mistake of having a thought in her
mind and then vocalizing it online for
many female writers and public figures
this day-to-day harassment is their life
earlier this year
writer Amanda Hess detailed her
experience the threats were obviously
distressing it was an anonymous person
on Twitter threatening to come to my
house to rape me to cut off my head and
in case you think she's exaggerating
here are some of the tweets she's
referring to happy to say we live in the
same state I'm looking you up and when I
find you I'm going to rape you and
remove your head and I am 36 years old I
did 12 years for manslaughter I killed a
woman like you who decided to make fun
of guys which is horrifying for so
many reasons first he put manslaughter
in quotes like he still doesn't think
it's a crime and also he put his age
like he's writing the world's worst
OkCupid profile I'm 36 years old I've
killed before I've got a pretty weird
shaped penis the thing is when Amanda
Hess went to the police she quickly
discovered how ill-equipped they can be
to deal with this sort of thing in my
home state of California it's a crime to
threaten bodily harm against another
person when I received my most sort of
recent bout of threats said the police
officer who came to my door didn't even
understand what Twitter was had no idea
how to investigate such a crime and I'm
not even sure knew that it it was
criminal so it's hard to know what to do
when you're put in that situation that's
a problem because the police cannot
investigate the crime if they genuinely
don't understand the medium in which it
happened if someone tried to drown you
you don't want the police saying I get
the murder attempts but what's this
water thing you keep bringing up is it
like air but a bit more Chokey is that
what it is and we're not just threatened
and harassed online the Internet has
thrown up a whole new way to wreck their
lives it's called revenge porn you may
have heard of it it's when naked photos
of people are posted online without
their consent and it can be devastating
this is anne-marie Chiarini an English
professor who let her then-boyfriend
take some private photos of her now
after they broke up he sent them to her
employer and her son's kindergarten
teacher and then this happened I
received an anonymous email at work that
a profile had been created of me someone
was pretending to be me and they were
nude pictures on this profile so it
googled my name and the porn web site
xhampster came up and there was my first
and last name the name of the college
where I teach the town where I live and
a solicitation for sex now that
obviously sounds like a nightmare and
sadly the horror of that situation led
her to some pretty dark places my actual
thoughts were this was mine this is my
life this is never gonna end so I need
to end my life because I could not live
like that so after the I found the
profile I attempted suicide now you
would assume that it's illegal to do
that to someone the problem is there is
no federal law specifically against
revenge porn and in Maryland where she
lived revenge porn was not illegal at
the time in fact only 23 states have
passed laws specifically against revenge
porn in the other twenty-seven it's one
of those things that should be
explicitly illegal but isn't like using
a golf umbrella in Manhattan or
returning from a semester abroad in
Spain and insisting on calling it
Barcelona you are the worst the worst
the point is the point is if you are a
victim of revenge porn in one of those
27 states your options are limited
you can try to pursue stalking or
harassment charges but those laws may
not always apply or you can file a civil
suit against the person who did it but
as a noorie tyranny found out you face
an uphill battle I did go to lawyers in
2010 to handle this civilly and the
first one said well you know you really
should get better boyfriends I won't
take this case the second one I
approached said well it's gonna be a
$5,000 upfront retainer and this could
run anywhere from ten to fifteen
thousand when all said and done I'm a
single mom of two I work two jobs I
don't have $5,000
nevermind 15 yeah of course you don't
because most people don't keep a shoebox
full of money marked just in case a
total piece of tries to ruin my
life now no you could ask the website to
take the photos down if you own the
copyright but if they refuse then
winning your lawsuit might entail doing
something absolutely mind-blowing you
can sue but to do that you've got to
register the copyright which brings us
the cold hard truth in the most extreme
case you've gotta send pictures of your
naked body to the Copyright Office
that's in Washington yes to stop
strangers from seeing pictures of their
naked body some women have had to send
more strangers more pictures of their
naked body we are one step away from
trying to protect our children in the
future by having the copyright symbol
tattooed onto their genitals at birth
look just to be safe let's take her to
Vipers ink Shack we don't know what kind
of she could end up meeting this
situation is insane and as one expert
found the official response to victims
ranges from offensive to ridiculous I've
interviewed 60 victims of online
harassment what they're often told is
look either if it's revenge when you
shared pictures with your ex he owns it
now like sorry that you trusted the
person but it's kind of your fault right
or they're told look if it's just
harassment generally like turn off your
computer ignore it it'll go away but
turn off your computer is simply not
practical almost every job requires the
internet now somewhere right now in the
world there is a yak herder going why is
the Wi-Fi so slow I'll herd these yaks
after lunch
and that whole distinctly victim-blaming
sentiment of if you didn't want this to
happen you shouldn't have taken photos
he's hardwired into mainstream culture
just watch how the news talks about this
whenever it comes up how best to avoid
this problem experts say don't take
pictures and then share them I think
that the teachable moment and the
takeaway is you just can't take these
pictures you know what
don't take negatives - one of the
solutions have promised don't take
pictures of yourself naked oK we've said
that good point
kids don't take pictures of yourself
naked and put it on the Internet's it's
gonna come up some point and what if it
doesn't come up until you're a parent
and then you got excuse me are you
talking about for stop not taking
pictures doesn't always work sometimes
these photos come from hacked webcams
but regardless of that it doesn't matter
how it happens because here's a fun game
insert any other crime into those same
sentences listen guys if you don't want
to get burgled don't live in a house if
you're a parents how are you gonna
explain that break-in to your kids
I'm well aware that asking law
enforcement to police speech is a dicey
proposition
no one wants them trolling through
message boards looking for violent
language but if a woman turns up to a
police station say someone threatened
her life on Twitter the answer what
Twitter is woefully inadequate and as
for a revenge porn we're going to need
some new laws unfortunately there are
plans to introduce a bill in Congress
called the intimate Privacy Protection
Act that aims to address non-consensual
pornography and we've obtained an
exclusive video of one representatives
genuinely moving speech about balancing
First Amendment rights and protecting
victims
I got you again you're a bunch of idiots
anon the king of pranks
yeah if passed this law as drafted would
make it a crime to post revenge porn and
don't worry it would still leave us with
plenty of internet porn to keep us going
and also the law would carve out
exceptions for the bona fide Public
Interest meaning that if say a public
figure like Anthony Weiner texts ative
penis around we could all still enjoy
that story not being able to enjoy it
would not be a danger although the truth
is the law can only do so much companies
need to be much more diligent about
clamping down on this and they are
slowly coming around in recent months
Twitter and reddit banned revenge porn
on their sites and just this Friday
Google finally announced after much
prodding it would remove photos of
revenge porn from search results upon
request and for Google to do that is not
nothing because we all know not even
vindictive perverts will use Bing they
won't it not even they will go near that
thing
they're not monsters
and for the rest of us it comes down to
to us and to fundamentally changing the
way that we think about the internet cuz
too often you hear people play down the
dangers of the internet by saying well
relax it's not real life but it is and
it always has been the whole point of
those AOL ads 20 years ago was that what
you did online would affect your life
immediately nowadays you can click a
button and buy a book meet your spouse
or ruin someone's life sometimes those
last two are the same click but we we
all know the Internet is an incredible
tool but like most tools it can be used
as a weapon and we've allowed things to
get to a place where women can fear for
their lives for something they said
online and find themselves mailing their
genitals to Washington in order to
maintain their privacy and perhaps we
would have dealt with this earlier if
only those AOL ads have looked something
like this
every day the Internet is making it
easier for people to live work and play
hey Dan ready for the game I'm just
finishing up here with my new kayaking
friends wow that's a really specific
thing to say listen I'm not gonna be
able to make the game tonight
oh why well I have to go out into the
streets and scream obscenities at women
that I don't even know and then after
that I got a hand write letters to all
the Golden Girls telling them that I'm
gonna down their throats and then
after that I got to bring these naked
photos of my ex-wife to her office and
show them to everyone that she works
with because she's such a it's
gonna take hours hey we can do all of
that before we go you know right know
with the internet look it's easy
see here's a random woman from
Minneapolis who just said how she felt
about something you want me to make her
fear for her life why not
but how done incredible what else can
this thing do to women with the internet
the only limit to how miserable you can
make another human being its how angry
you are and how fast you can type hey
well what about those photos of my
ex-wife oh that's my favorite part all
you have to do is scan them into this
site and then people can see it
instantly their boss for friends for
parents everyone everyone everyone
everyone everyone and this is legal
there's no federal law explicitly
against it that seems insane doesn't it
yeah it really does anyway come on we're
gonna be late for the game
can't wait afterwards I'm gonna some of
my new kayaking buddies a Dark Carnival
of humanity's most wretched impulses Oh
fourth wasn't a good guess
you